yeah my parents thought i was uh because
i was always on xbox voice chat talking
to people they thought
when i started voice acting they were
like oh connor's just talking to his
friends on xbox
so they didn't know what i was doing
he's just talking in funny voices
why is he saying the same thing over and
over again huh doing different
inflections that's really [ __ ] weird
oh never mind you're probably playing
xbox con is a weird one
got some weird hobbies right yeah yeah i
mean i think my parents definitely when
i was a kid they saw me as like the
weird kid
of the like of like the four right they
were like he's the strange one but
normally things work out in the end
he'll find his way
yeah that's normally the way that it was
i mean like growing up i do sometimes i
do wish that i did have brothers and
sisters
um because i feel like i don't know i
don't know i don't know how you guys
feel about your siblings but
i feel like there's nothing that can
want to be raised without brothers or
sisters
i think now that i've had them i just
couldn't imagine not being raised with
siblings
yeah the same i don't know yeah i i
can't imagine just having to share
everything though
that's well you don't have to that's why
that's why how you learn to lie
right although i did have to share my
xbox and that was horrible we'd have to
like swap every hour and i'm like i
can't even get a good gaming session in
here for now are you kidding me i mean
that's why i'm glad like
the first like game console we goal was
game boy advances because we had one
each that was the first game
that was the first console you got yeah
yeah yeah or any like yeah well like any
console that we could actually
share right or wasn't like a two-player
thing because we had like the n64 like
that too but yeah if you have two
controllers you can play together yeah
but can't quite do that on a on a
handheld console right now
so it was fun it was [ __ ] fine like
you know sometimes i'd want to get on
the n64
player one player game like [ __ ]
donkey kong 64 or super mario 64 or
something
you can't play that with my sister yeah
so i'm just like [ __ ] what do we do
let's get a handheld console and just
play whatever the [ __ ] games we want
together
problem solved man i miss being [ __ ]
stupid as a kid
i do because i i miss i had this thought
the other day i miss
how simple it was just to like find
happiness in something right
so my first game so my first game
console
all game device was a gameboy color okay
right and my parents bought it for me in
france
and yeah they were like what game do you
want i'm like pokemon
yeah i didn't know at the time so it
turns out the game was in french
obviously through in france
um but somehow still managed to complete
the whole thing wow
when i was like eight or something and
i'm like
i would not have the patience to [ __ ]
do that now no no
yeah i don't know i don't know what the
[ __ ] was going on i don't know what any
of the moves did but i think like
eight-year-old me
had just understood that this set of
letters
did this funny thing that did a lot of
damage because i've just been playing it
so much yeah i think by the time i got
to the elite four i think nearly all my
pokemon were level 100.
oh my god it was literally just trial by
fire right i was literally just grinding
and i'm like how the [ __ ] did i do that
i'm so dumb i wish being that dumb or i
could just throw myself at something
like that
yeah like i remember because i also i
mean i got the game boy advance but the
first couple of games i got were game
boy color games yeah because you could
play the gameboy color games
advance which i was like oh my god
technology but um
yeah i remember like the part where i
think about it now where it's like
i definitely had too much time as a kid
that i could not sink into my adulthood
was when
i managed to on my pokemon sapphire
cartridge
i played it so much that i maxed out the
in time clock
oh my god like i found out
that on pokemon sapphire on gameboy
advance is it one thousand hours
yeah 999 hours 99 minutes is the
furthest it will go
did you just leave this thing on how
much i played it
i see it man when you're a kid you just
get obsessed every moment because
especially the gameboy advance like
looking back on it now this thing's
[ __ ]
tiny yeah you could put that in like
jeans pocket or like a jacket pocket and
take it everywhere the benchtown
because i think it was literally on
wheel kids was the game boy uh advance
sp
oh yeah oh that was so good only the
cool rich kids yeah
well the sp was like the best one
because that [ __ ] like just it would
literally
fit in your like your tiny child jeans
yeah yeah it was amazing
i remember i remember one of my japanese
friends brought it to school
and it was like boys
[ __ ] reading like the awful god i
think actually the first model of the sp
didn't have a backlight it was like the
second month oh really it's just the
more popular model i think yeah yeah
yeah yeah but uh
i had an sp and i got one because uh my
friend got one and i saw him playing it
and for like christmas i was like mom
i want nothing more than a gameboy
advance sp
and you know what game i played the most
on it [ __ ] gba game
i played pokemon trading card game oh
you played that game once again
yeah yeah it's so good i mean i remember
like oh god
sorry i i had a finalization of the
story uh one time i thought
you know i was so addicted to this thing
right i would literally walk around the
house with it i would sleep with it oh
yeah of course
if i was walking down the stairs i would
play game boy walking downstairs yeah
yeah yeah i was like
i'd be there if i was gonna better play
it yeah i would even
if i went to pee i would i would play
with it okay so i would pee with it
one time i dropped it down the toilet
not sure how it happened i was playing i
was playing pokemon trading card game
because that was the cartridge that was
in there yeah i was playing it whilst
peeing you know you know you're like 12
you're
a little dicks out you're like yeah i
don't know how i dropped it i dropped it
and i was like
how do i explain this how do i tell that
i don't have a gameboy sp
anymore and uh yeah it didn't work and
did you lie no because it smelled a piss
as well
for some reason i checked if the pokemon
trading card came
still work still worked of course
because i plugged it into my uh the old
gameboy caller i had yeah yeah
but uh yeah so i had to go to my mom i
was like mom um
so this is kind of like embarrassing but
uh
i dropped my game boy down the toilet
and she was like
how did you drop your game boy down the
[ __ ] toilet
and i'm like i don't know i just you
know i just really enjoy playing it
and my family [ __ ] rinsed me for like
five years
yeah that was my kid i'd [ __ ] rinse
them down did you know how expensive a
gameboy advanced sp is
at that age but they loved it purely for
the comedic purposes every time we'd
meet someone
like this is callum he's he's very
successful very smart this is connor he
dropped his game boy down the [ __ ]
toilet
and i was so sad for like four months i
was just
every window i was like
did you ever get another one i did six
months later for my birthday i was like
wow
really yeah i don't wait i'd like
literally i remember like for six months
i was like playing game boy
color again yeah she's playing pokemon
trading card game and all this shitty
game boys parents are nice man if
if i did that my parents would never buy
me a game card i think they felt
so bad for me because of how like
distraught i was and i think they
thought i was gonna get over it but like
i was sad for like half a year oh yeah
it's like dropping like a [ __ ] it's
like dropping a laptop down yeah yeah
i could not get over it and i think my
parents at some point were like
all right i think we should get him
another one or maybe he's like not gonna
recover
maybe he's never gonna let this go then
i wouldn't have i wouldn't have let this
guy